(upbeat music)
- Well, welcome to a special
episode of the Addy Hour.
Today I'm honored to be able to host
two scientific directors
from the National Institutes of Health,
for a conversation we're
really gonna be focusing
on physical and mental wellness
and also talking about racial disparities
specifically within the context
of our scientific research
and in the context of
our scientific workforce,
also with an emphasis on
our scientific trainees.
So I'm honored to
welcome two guests today.
The first of which is Dr. Amy Newman.
Dr. Newman is the scientific director
at the National Institute on Drug Abuse,
a role that she has served in since 2020.
And prior to that,
she was actually the
acting scientific director
for two years.
Dr. Newman received her
undergraduate degree in chemistry
at Mary Washington College
and that also went on after that
to a PhD in medicinal chemistry
from the Medical College of Virginia
and Virginia Commonwealth University,
then went on to post-doctoral
training at NIDDK.
Dr. Newman is someone who has
been prolific in the field
and has contributed immensely
to our knowledge in this area.
As it was stated during
the NIH press release
when she took this position,
she has performed work
focusing on design,
synthesis and evaluation
of central nervous system acting agents
as potential therapeutics
for substance use disorders.
She has published over 300 articles,
is also an inventor on
multiple NIH patents
And one of the things I really
appreciate about Dr. Newman
in addition to her outstanding science
is her emphasis on
training and mentorship.
So in 2019, she received a
Kirschstein Mentoring Award
from the office of the director of the NIH
and in 2018 was recognized
as a remarkable woman
in medicinal chemistry
from the American Chemical Society.
So someone who has had a lot
of impact both scientifically
and in terms of people's
training and development
over the years.
So I'm honored to be able
to welcome Dr. Newman
to the Addy Hour podcast.
- Thank you so much, Nii.
- Oh, thanks so much for being here.
- Our second guest, which
I'm pleased to introduce
is Dr. Luigi Ferrucci,
who is the scientific director
at the National Institute on Aging.
Dr. Ferrucci is a geriatrician
and an epidemiologist
who conducts research
on the causal pathways
leading to progressive
physical and cognitive decline
in older persons.
He received a lot of
his training at Florence
at the University of Florence in Italy
where he also received his PhD
and has board certification in geriatrics.
He served on the faculty
at that university
for quite a while,
an associate professor of biology,
human physiology, and statistics
at the University of Florence.
And also between 1985 and 2002,
was the chief of geriatric rehabilitation
at the Department of Geriatric Medicine
and director of the Laboratory
of Clinical Epidemiology
at the Italian National
Institute of Aging.
So Luigi, as someone who
has performed research
across several different continents,
a lot of work at both
in the US and in Europe,
a lot of longitudinal studies
specifically looking at
risk factors for mobility,
disability in older persons.
In September of 2002,
he became the chief of a
longitudinal studies section
at the National Institute on Aging
and the director
of the Baltimore
Longitudinal Study on Aging.
And then in 2001, became the
scientific director at NIA.
So someone who has a longstanding
history in the field,
has made several contributions,
and has also served in several
different leadership roles.
So again, honored to be able
to welcome Dr. Luigi Ferrucci
to the Addy Hour podcast as well.
- Thank you very much.
I'm looking forward to this conversation.
- Yes, I am as well.
And I feel like this
is a two for one deal.
I know the two of you interact quite a bit
and I'm honored to be able
to host both of you simultaneously
and to hear some
complimentary perspectives
that you all have in your
roles as scientific directors
and in your roles in mentoring
and in leadership as well.
So as our listeners know,
I always like to start out just
checking in with our guests
to see how they're doing.
And before we get there, though,
I did want to put this in
context a little bit as well,
because I think there are
some things as scientists
that we all share in common,
especially with everything that's gone on
over the last 18 months,
I think a lot of us as scientists
have become defacto
experts for our friends
and our colleagues and families,
whether we feel like we
fit that role well or not.
But just with the way
that science has been talked
about publicly recently,
obviously with COVID and
also with the last election,
I feel like science has been
elevated in the conversation,
some for good, some for not so good,
but it's given us an opportunity
in a lot of ways as well.
But I know for me personally,
and others I've talked to,
we've sometimes become defacto
infectious disease experts
or vaccine experts or
immunologists or epidemiologists.
Of course, Luigi, in your
case, that is appropriate
in terms of the epidemiology.
But I did want to also just talk
about the ways that we are also all
going through this as well
just like everybody else,
and not always an easy journey.
So if we could just start
talking a little bit
about how you've personally
experienced the last 18 months
and how that has also played
out in your professional role
as a scientist working
with scientific trainees.
So Dr. Newman, if we could start with you.
- Thank you, Nii.
It has been a roller coaster,
and I think that I
probably have many people
on that roller coaster with me.
As you noted, I became the
actual scientific director
just in November.
I was the acting scientific
director before that.
So within this 18 months,
I was also applying for the job
that I was in and hope to remain in
experiencing the many changes
that we had to quickly make
to have people, first of all,
work from home and figure
out how to do that,
and then slowly get back,
but even now being distanced
and masked and so forth,
it has been quite an adjustment.
And I think that where
I get the most thrill
is that we're doing it.
And despite the fact
that it's not been easy
and there's certainly
been trauma along the way,
we have figured it out for the most part
at just about every level,
not to say that we don't want to get back,
we all want to get back,
we want to be together and
do the work that we do best
and that we love most,
but I think that I'm really delighted
with the resilience that I've seen,
and for the most part, the flexibility
that we've had to have at every level
in order to kind of keep
on doing what we're doing,
because we can't stop.
We're scientists and
not only do we love it,
but I think,
you know, I really think
the work that we do
is so important to continue to do
in the best way that we can.
- Yeah, very well said
and there's a lot of hope there as well.
I like the full picture that you gave,
not that it's been easy
or that there haven't been
challenges along the way,
but that things are still moving forward.
I think that's really important
and I appreciate you
bringing that out as well.
What about you, Luigi?
- Certainly, I agree with
most of what Amy said.
It's been challenging.
I think the most challenging part to me
has been losing that direct connection,
that unspoken language that
connects people and scientists
and being able and make an effort
to continuously connect with them
so that you become the
thread that (mumbles)
the spirit of it.
And I have to say, also what Amy say,
I'm amazed how people have
responded to this challenge,
how the scientific creativity
did not get run down.
People found any possible way
to maintain attention
and focus on their work.
They could not collect data.
They used the data they had
to analyze them and writing their paper.
They kept having their
lab meeting virtually.
I have to say that people
have been marvelous
to me how they,
of course there's been weaknesses,
there have been, some of our trainees,
and then not only the trainees,
have been really subject to great stress.
And for me, it's been an attempt
to support them in many different ways.
And at the same time,
I was dealing with my personal situation
because my family is in
Italy so we couldn't travel.
So I stay 18 months
without visiting my family.
And so there was the
stress of not traveling,
the stress of having to maintain (mumbles)
so that at the end of
this period we will have
an NIA and NIDA are still alive
and can produce that
important work that they do.
It's a mixed bag.
I learn a lot.
I think that if we get out from here,
the grief of COVID-19 release,
we'll do things differently
because we have learned something.
- Yeah, that's very well said as well.
There's so many important
points that you both brought up,
just the realities of the whole thing.
And I like that you talked
about the personal aspect
for you as well 'cause
you're still leading,
even though you yourself
haven't seen your family in 18 months.
And then Amy, as you mentioned,
just the resilience that's been
there as well on both sides,
even while there are
challenges along the way.
Several different points I
wanted to actually follow up on,
but one, Luigi, you mentioned it
and hinted at the expectation in a sense
for NIA and for NIDA.
There's an expectation that
the work will continue.
How have you seen that impact
yourselves and those around you?
Has that been good pressure?
Has it been challenging pressure?
Especially as you said, some
have thrived under this,
but some have also had
challenges with the stress.
Anything that you've noticed
that's come out with that?
- I think globally, we
are doing fantastic.
I think that there has been
an episode of difficulty,
but even those that when under stress,
adequately supported, they
were able to come out positive.
I've seen that the people
were highly receptive
to discussion, to communication.
And so in general,
you know, certainly everything went
as perfect as we wanted it to.
And you know, one of
the things that you said
at the beginning I think
was very important.
You know, at some point everybody
became expert in epidemiology
of viral disease.
You know, everybody was a virologist,
everybody was trying to write on COVID-19.
Initially, I was kind of upset at that,
you know, this is the science,
you can't really improvise yourself to be,
but then I realized that to some extent
this was a coping strategy.
Instead of being only the receiver
of the negative effect of COVID-19,
being a protagonist and
contribute in some way another
with your scientific expertise
the solution of the problem.
And so I realized that all these
trying to elaborate the new ideas,
especially in the field of aging
where COVID-19's really
been hitting the weaker.
Older people are certainly
one of the weakest
component of our population,
it was really extraordinarily positive.
So in the end,
I think that my view is very positive.
As I said, we'll come out from this
a little bit better than we were before,
that's what I think.
- I think from our side,
there's two groups that
really suffered a lot.
And one were those who
have small children at home
or school age children at home.
And this does hit not only our
post-docs and junior faculty,
but also many of our administrators
who we completely depend
on to keep us going forward
and having to figure out
how to teach your children from home
and get your kindergardener on a laptop
and those kinds of things
I think was extremely
stressful for that group.
And I think some of them really felt
like they were not able to move forward
in the job that they wanted to do
because they had this whole new job
that was extremely new to them
and not something they
were necessarily good at
and they had to do it,
there was no other choice.
I think that was really tough.
The other group,
our clinical researchers,
and we work with substance use disorders
and that has skyrocketed during COVID.
I mean that is just a tremendous
number of overdose deaths,
much higher than it has
been in several years
and can't even do our patient studies,
we can't do our clinical work right now
to the degree that we had before.
We've just started to open up
some clinical studies this summer,
but it's at a much slower capacity.
And so I think our clinical
researchers feel frustrated
because this is what they do
and that's the population
that they want to serve.
It's really suffered.
And they're kind of, if anything slow,
but almost stopped in their tracks
for the last 18 months.
- What have been some of the ways
that you all have tried to
address that in the meantime,
just being in that place of,
it sounds like a mixture
of one, feeling stuck,
and two, not being able to help the people
that you feel like you're
called to serve as well.
So how do you address that?
- Well, I think that
the most difficult part
is that when you are in the building,
when you meet people in the corridor,
when you get coffee with them,
when you have all these
informal meeting with them,
that they are not predisposed,
you keep track of what is happening.
You're feeling the sense
of whether there is something
wrong going on in the people,
the gesture, the posture,
the way they say hello
to you at the moment.
And I felt that I was
completely missing that.
For example, this is a stupid example,
but to tell you how
much this was important.
During Christmas time last year,
I had so much longing for the
people that work in my office
of the scientific director,
that I visited each one.
I went to their home,
I saw them for one minute,
but we were face-to-face.
And I got, I don't think
they got a lot from it,
but I did, I did like,
I felt that that human
connection, what it constitutes,
and what I'm afraid
is that while our
productivity will be high,
we established those
informal and heart connection
is not gonna be automatic,
we will need to work hard to do that.
And I intend to do it
by meeting with people,
creating informal way of creating groups,
even not based on the scientific,
but Thursday last week
at the end of the day,
we went for a walk, masking, everything,
it was incredible,
30 people just for two months of walking,
but interacting with them
and see how bright
and inventive and creative they are,
I think that gave me a lot.
But I think also they felt
that their scientific director,
their leader was with them,
and I want them to feel
that I am with them,
I learn from them and I feel they are
in my same journey.
- That's great, all in
the journey together.
Amy, anything you were
gonna add there as well?
- I did not do the one-on-one like that,
but one thing that we did
was that we had listening
sessions on Zoom,
but one-on-one with every
single faculty member
and they had just 30 minutes,
but I had two questions.
One is tell me about one
most exciting project
that you're working on
or you want to work on.
And then tell me the
challenges that you have
to prevent you from
moving forward as quickly
or as effectively as you want to.
And they were,
and we did this with all the faculty
and then we did it in groups
with our staff scientists
and staff clinicians
and we even did a group of the post-docs
and I think that it was so super fun.
It was great to see that
enthusiasm despite the situation.
It was very informative to
hear what the challenges were.
Many of them I knew, but
some of them I didn't
and also I didn't know
how many people found certain
things to be challenging.
And so that gave me my orders
to move forward and try
to fix those things.
But especially with like my
scientists and staff clinicians,
they said, "I've never had a chance
to talk to my scientific director.
This is the first time I've ever talked
to my scientific director,
they ever asked me to
have a conversation."
I got a lot out of that,
but I think they did too.
And the other thing
that I did this summer,
'cause we could do it,
I have a nice backyard,
we live kind of out in the country
and we lined up big picnic tables
and I invited my whole
group for outdoor lunch
and I made lunch and we were all outside
and it was so fun,
I mean we hung out here for hours
and it was just a great
chance to be together.
And again, I loved it,
but I think they really loved it too.
And it was just a one-off,
I wish I could do it more often.
This is something that
I really like to do.
Luigi and I both love cooking
and we love to entertain
and it's something that we've
really not been able to do
like we want to,
but those little tiny gestures
seem to have been useful for all of us.
- Yeah, that's great
and I appreciate you
peeling back the layers
'cause as you were both talking about how
groups are still here, people
are still moving forward,
that was one thing I was
just really wondering,
like the layers underneath
that what you had done.
And it sounds like it's
been some new creativity
in that sense too.
And as we were talking before we started,
the session as well,
the things that we don't get
trained on as scientists,
but which I think we're all
becoming much more aware
of the importance of,
you know, just having people over
or having those touch points,
Luigi, having your drive-by's
to just connect with people
and connect and chat with them
and how important that is for
all of us in so many ways.
- You know that,
but you learn more and more
that only place that make
people enthusiastic and happy
becomes productive.
You need to make them
wanting to come to work.
You need to make them being thinking
that the best thing they can do
is to interact with the group.
And if you're able to do that,
that is an incredibly powerful force.
You don't really have to
teach them how to pipette.
You need to tell them if they
come here and they pipette,
they will make a discovery and
they will be extremely happy
because of that discovery.
I think that that is
the most important thing
that we need to do as leaders.
And then they will grow
professionally by themselves.
You know somebody told me once
that when you have trainees,
you don't have to take
their hands continuously.
You are like a flight control person
that follow them and you
tell them where to go,
but they actually know where to go
and you only intervene
when there is bad weather
or when they for some reason
are losing their direction
and then you have to go there,
put them in the right direction
and then allow them to fly by themself.
And I find that creating
a good environment
and a safety net where they know
if they get in trouble,
there's somebody there
that will help them,
it's really the best way
to handle our trainees.
- Yeah, it sounds like
it's building a community
and making sure that it's
sincere and authentic
and that people know that
you're there to be supportive,
which is so important.
Amy, would you say those
are similar principles
that you try to apply as well?
- It reminded me of a quote
from your previous podcast,
Dr. Ressler and Jones Marlin,
when they said in quotes,
"Cohesion can buffer trauma."
And I love that.
I wrote that down because I thought, yes,
if we have that community where
we have these relationships,
which I think are so important,
and like Luigi, I want
people to love their science,
I want them to be able to pipette,
or in my case, I want them
to be able to run a reaction
and not blow themselves
up, it's really important.
But having said that,
what I always say to them
is it's as important
to really work on your
communication skills
and your development of relationships
'cause as chemists,
we can make compounds all day long,
but if I don't have neuroscientists
and behavioral pharmacologists
and computational biophysicist
and all those people
to help me put those
molecules into perspective
and to help me know what tools are needed
and then give me the opportunity to say,
wow, we just made something
that nobody else has ever made
and we just locked the biological secret
that would have continued to
be elusive without that tool.
And that's the thing I think
is so much fun about what we do
and I hope is the role model
that we play as scientific directors
for all those who work with us.
- Yeah so important, so well said,
just the importance of
that diverse community
in terms of our science and
our teams and things like that.
And of course that brings up a topic
that I wanted to kind of touch on as well
'cause clearly the scientific
diversity is so important,
but we've also been just
trying to walk through
all the racial diversity issues,
the racial reckoning
that many of us are trying to walk through
and hoping that it's a
true racial reckoning,
but then also seeing ups
and downs along the way
and all the racial disparities.
I know both of your institutes
have aspects of health
disparities research as well,
but I'm just curious
as we've been talking along
the lines of the COVID,
like how has those components
impacted you all on a day-to-day basis
in your roles as directors
and in your interactions with your teams?
- So I guess one of the things
that's come out of it for us
is again, this kind of grassroots growing
of acknowledgement of
the importance of that
and not only do we have
kind of a faculty-led diversity committee,
but we have a trainee-led, started,
and it's called the IDEA Committee,
inclusion, diversity, equity,
and they're educating us.
So every month, they send out an email
where they're they're explaining
some aspect of racial diversity
or like during black history
month or different things.
They're educating us,
they're bringing speakers
into our institution.
What they are doing is
being part of a solution,
which frankly we need.
We need everyone I think
to be part of that solution
and to try to help us improve
and really recognize the
importance of diversity
in that community
and how it really brings science
to the very best that it can be.
- That's great to hear.
Luigi, anything you want to add there?
- I think that what Amy said
is absolutely the right direction.
I have the feeling that
we need to attract more.
As an NIH environment,
we have so much to offer
and so we're not doing enough outreach.
We're not showing our cards around,
showing how much being in NIH
could be a very successful environment,
for everybody,
for underrepresented minority,
the disadvantaged young trainees.
I think that at some
point I did not realize
that I was part of the problem
because yes I thought,
we need to outreach to minorities,
diversify our workforce is important,
that's one of many things
that I needed to do.
And I am glad that at some point
this was transformed into a central theme.
And so we got a lot of information
and in a way, I realize much more
that this was an incredibly important part
of what NIH need to transform itself
and become a true scientific enterprise.
- That time, I think that many, many
try to address the problem,
I still feel that we don't
have enough people coming in
when we advertise for our position.
So what we need to do
is to go and stimulate
the progress of young investigator
that are attracted by coming to NIH
and realize their scientific dreams.
I think that we're doing
a little bit of outreach,
but I think we should do better.
I'm discussing with some of
the other scientific director,
we should create a movie
about what NIH does,
showcase some example of high success,
show the technology and
the good studies at NIH
and then go to the different
academic institution.
If we do not expand that base,
I don't think the solution
is fighting for the few candidates.
is that Yale and NIH fight
to get that candidate
and offer more.
We need to expand that base
'cause the base is there.
So we need to find ways to realize that.
And I think that many, many people now
are really considering
that's it's an important
part of our mission
and so I am hopeful that
with some up and down,
as you were explaining,
I think that puts the political
situation where we live
will impact that,
but if we have enough time,
I think we can make a
dent on this problem.
- And again, that makes me
think about the importance
of the community aspect as well,
both the community and the communication,
because you're talking about
making sure that the community
is projecting and expanding,
but that through the communication
of those in the community
to make sure that other
communities are pulled in as well
and I think that's really important
is what the environment is like.
And Amy, as you were mentioning,
it's encouraging to hear
about the trainees stepping up
and providing those resources
and all those things as well.
I was gonna ask a follow-up question there
because that even in itself
can sometimes be a
point of tension as well
in terms of where the
onus is with the trainees
as they are going through their training
and taking on extra work.
So how has that whole dynamic played out?
Because we've seen it in a lot of ways,
Black in Neuro is a good example as well,
where the trainees have really stepped up
and done a tremendous job,
but also know that they
need to balance their time
in terms of being trainees
and that they also need the
support of administrators
to actually implement some of the changes
and to be able to incorporate.
So have those conversations
been part of the process?
From your response, I'm
thinking it has been.
- The thing is that
what a wonderful time to learn it, right?
So when you're in this
kind of post-baccalaureate
or post-doctoral time,
you're learning science
and how to figure out how
to do research and so forth,
but also that you're not just a scientist.
As Luigi said in the beginning,
if we're just scientists,
we're not doing our job.
We really need to learn
to do these other things
and find out what we're good at.
Not all of us are good at all things,
that's why the diversity comes into it
as being so important.
And so, yes, I think some of our trainees
end up spending a lot of time
on these committee responsibilities
and not so much time in the laboratory
and then sometimes
we have to reel them back in a little bit,
but on the other hand,
if that's what they really love
and that's how they really contribute,
then I think that that's great.
I mean one thing I was gonna go back to
with regard to the community
and not the scientific community,
but in Baltimore, for example,
people wonder why we're,
the National Institute on
Drug Abuse is in Baltimore
and it's largely
because Baltimore had
the drug abuse problem,
but those that didn't,
Baltimore has had an opioid crisis
for a lot longer than the
rest of the country has,
and yet we still have
trouble recruiting subjects
into our studies.
And I think in part,
there is this they don't
know that we exist,
that we're there,
in part, there is a distrust
government or mental work,
and we have to somehow figure it out.
And I don't any of the
answers for all this.
This is really where I'm trying
to find better ways to do things
and trying to encourage
our trainees and others,
faculty members,
to try to break down
some of those barriers
because we are not going to
address the health disparities,
particularly of substance use disorder,
if we can't get subjects
into our clinical trials and our studies
and understand what
works and what doesn't.
And that's a big challenge
that we are really not doing well,
and I think that that's one
of our big challenges going forward.
- Yeah and it seems like it has so many
ramifications as well
as you've talked about,
just from the research itself
and the community and impact.
I know Amy within,
and I'm gonna not remember
exactly the name of it,
but I know there is a big push
to make sure that there is more diversity
in terms of (mumbles) studies,
so some of the local Baltimore groups
have gotten involved in that
with the African ancestry recruitment.
I think Hafjazeera and Yasmin
are both on that advisory board.
I'm forgetting the name of the
principal investigators there
but I know they're working
with local church leaders
and things like that.
Are there conversations
about trying to do similar
types of things like that
within NIA or at NIDA?
I'm just curious,
I know we're outside of the
training realm a little bit,
but that has such an
important impact on society
and what the trainees are walking into.
I'm just curious to hear
how those conversations
are going.
- Obviously it's connected.
I think that one of the things
that is happening with NIA
that is now leading the
research on Alzheimer's disease
and related dementia is Jack
created a new initiative
which his called CARD,
a Center for Alzheimer's
Disease and Related Dementia.
We will have a new building in the test
that is currently,
I will say half finished,
we can see already.
But one of the thing that we want to do
is exactly what I said,
do research on neurodegenerative disease,
they spa across multiple populations
so we can leverage on the fact
that there are multiple condition
and look at the differences
and the similarity
and connect them to the knowledge.
I think that the genetic
assume much more sense
and become much my informative
when it's diversified.
But one thing I want to say
that is connected to what Amy said,
and that really is I struggle with
is that the Washington, Baltimore area
is so filled with research institution,
that people are kind of
tired in participating
because we don't give them back enough.
We need to find ways to
give back to the community.
When we involve them,
we need to find way that
people feel more involved,
people feel that they're
part of a project,
they're not just our animal
model for our studies.
And I do struggling to finding ways
because even some of the
ethical constraints we live in
not allow, for example,
to provide them care.
But I think we need to
bend these boundaries.
We need to find ways
so their research become
part of the community
and it's not using the
community to generate paper.
If we do that,
I think that the involvement of people
will be much, much higher.
- Oh, that's so important.
And it sounds, I mean you're hinting
at some of the policy
pieces around that as well,
but do you think there's also
a communication aspect of it?
Or is it one or the other, both in parcel?
- No, both of them, both of them.
I think that when people come
to the Baltimore
Longitudinal Study of Aging
and we ask them when they leave
after two, three day visit
to write down their impression,
one of the thing they want to know
is what do you do with
the data that we give you.
And so they want newsletter,
they want to be informed,
they want to know what their contribution
and their generosity resulting to.
And we try to do something but
maybe it's not strong enough.
- Hmm, yeah.
I keep saying the same thing, but again,
it sounds like community
and that community that extends
outside of the research,
but is involved in the community at large
and that we're all working
in the same goals together
as a community, whether we're
participants or researchers.
So I'll try not to keep saying
that, but it keeps coming up.
- It's the answer.
I think that that's a
brilliant idea, Luigi,
on how to amplify what
we're giving back to them
and help them recognize
that they're getting
something out of it too,
that's a really big challenge.
We have a clinic that
we provide treatment,
methadone and buprenorphine,
for people who are addicted to opioids,
but it's small and I think
we could expand that.
But then it gets into this
like are we using NIH research
dollars for treatment?
And so, again, there's
these back and forth.
I don't know that there's a clean answer,
but there's gotta be a better answer
than what we have right now.
- And it seems so important that, I mean,
in some ways the solution isn't there,
but it's also encouraging to hear
that that's a point that
you're both wrestling with
and thinking about and trying to improve.
- You know, one thing that we
are really trying to increase
is even like getting out
into the high schools
and going to the science fairs
and being judges and being involved.
And maybe, again, if we
can get the kids involved
and then they go home and
they talk to their parents
or their family members
or their church members
and kind of, again, this,
I'm sounding like I'm being redundant,
but this kind of grassroots way,
but I think that trickle
down just hasn't done it
and I think that maybe
that's another possibility.
- Yeah, yeah, so really
intentional in that sense as well.
- Yeah yeah, like we collect
money and we make little,
we give money awards that come from us
for these Baltimore science fairs,
just it's not a lot but it's a little bit
and not only do they win
but they get a little money
and it's kind of exciting.
I mean those are small things.
I think that there can be much
bigger ideas coming forward.
- Yeah, that's so
important in a lot of ways.
- I also want to loop
back and tie in, Amy,
one of the points that
you made earlier too
about the trainees and
everything they're doing
to really make large impact
and the balance with the science.
Because I feel like in a lot of ways,
at least for me personally,
I feel like the groups that are coming up
are doing a much better
job of that than I did
even when I was in that position.
You know, some of these
more public facing things
I didn't start till I
was well into my career,
it's kind of settled,
but I feel like that passion
is there and it's important
and they're running with
it in a lot of ways,
they're exemplary and things that,
we can all learn from that.
And then you also talked
about kind of the tension
between the research
and the outreach work.
And so how are you all
encouraging that or modeling that?
And then also, similarly,
in your roles as well,
are their ways that you
also try and balance that
in your own lives?
And how does that impact kind
of this ongoing conversation
and tension between different passions
and where to pursue them
and how to balance that.
So any insights that you all
have that you shared with
or continue to?
- I want to say it's true
and we do Titanic effort.
I know that there's no one single weekend
that I don't try to work
and to accomplish everything
that needs to be done.
But to put a difficult note,
I think that spending our day
from eight o'clock till
seven o'clock in the evening
in front of Skype or Zoom
doesn't make our life easier.
I think that,
I feel like at the end of the
day, I'm completely exhausted.
So why doing the same thing
that I was doing before COVID-19
require double of the effort?
I think that's important
to understand this.
And has we do it,
that we are,
let's say the struggling.
We need to be the one that never crack
because people should see us as an anchor
that they cannot be attached to.
Our scientists, our staff
scientists, our trainees,
are experiencing the same problem,
the same kind of exhaustion.
And so you go back to the
idea that the mutual support.
I think that, and you're
right when you say
that this generation are,
especially in the trainee,
people that are more
likely to help each other.
Some of them get into crisis,
the other come in and try
to be a support network.
This is certainly happening
in many of our labs,
even when there is a real crisis.
You can see that people get together,
if not physically, at least virtually
and create the support to each other.
And we need to encourage that.
You know, for example, in my lab,
there's one of my staff
scientists organize happy hours
every Friday afternoon
and people come and go and they're there
and that's an opportunity
for them to connect
and also to hear what's
happening to others.
I say before,
my fear is that something is happening
that will lead to something bad.
And I don't perceive that
because I'm not there because,
you know, you have
one-on-one conversation.
The buzz that is in the building
that you can hear without
paying attention is no longer there.
And that is the part that we're missing
that is really, really dangerous.
- I think that I have a very strong
self-preservation streak.
So I know that I cannot work 24/7
and in fact, I hate that term.
One of the things that I do every week
is I write a little message to
my whole intramural program,
it's just like from my
heart to their ears,
they can delete it or they can read it,
but it's always something personal.
And one of my messages
some months back was 24/7,
get rid of that term.
Nobody really works 24/7
and no one should even
say that they work 24/7.
And I think at the end,
I said something like,
the only thing you really
can do 24/7 is breathe
and I support by that.
- Yes, definitely well said, yeah,
so important.
- But I think that
you have to model that.
I think that it's just easy
to just always work and just
pedal as fast as you can
and I do think that in my
messages and just in my life,
I do try to exemplify that I love my work
and I love the work that we do
and the collaborations
we have and so forth,
but you know what,
I also made a dozen containers
of pesto this weekend
because I harvested a lot of my basil
or I'm having 12 people for crabs tonight
'cause my son just flew in from Wash-U,
he's a neurology resident,
he just flew in this afternoon
and we're having over all
of his friends for crabs.
We have to show that we
also are human beings
and that we have to be able
to take care of yourself
'cause if you're well is dry,
you don't want anything to give
and I don't think that
that's good for anybody.
- That's really important.
I'm glad that you're
being so vocal about that
in a lot of ways too.
Do you feel like that is
getting incorporated into the culture?
Because I would say if I asked
many of the trainees that I work with,
they would say that's not
always their impression.
Their impression is they
have to stay on the grind,
this is their formative years.
If they take a step back
or take a time to breathe and pause,
someone else will continue that work
and have the position
they were looking for.
So is that getting
incorporated in the culture
or do you think this is a
unique perspective that you're?
- What I can say about
that Nii is when I said,
we took a vacation this summer
and one of my messages I was going on vaca
and I had so many people
send me a messages and say,
thank you, now I feel
like I can go on vacation
or I can tell people I'm going on vacation
'cause we're so, in a leadership position,
I think a lot of times
it was so afraid to admit
that we've gone on vacation,
oh wow, we're not watching
the place every moment.
And I think that it's that, but yeah,
people need to keep on working hard.
- I think the balance
between life and work,
it's really important
and of course we need to do,
but I also think that
everybody's different.
I mean I don't think
that there is one measure
for everybody.
I think for some of the
trainees, for example,
working really, really
hard give them the sense
that they're not losing the
opportunity of their career.
Some are more relaxed
and they accept the idea
that maybe that this is happening to them,
but I always reinforce the idea
that NIH has been
fantastic in this crisis.
We have given to people,
we, they, I don't know who,
we've given them incredible flexibility.
You have to deal with the
children, deal with the children.
You don't have to quit work.
Because we understand that
the value of maintaining
the health of our society,
we alternate people, so we don't have
too much concentration of
people in the building.
There has been incredible support.
I have to tell you that
this amount of flexibility,
to some extent surprised
me that this was possible.
It was really a discovery.
And I think that has been
a really fantastic choice
to do that
because that allowed
people to relax enough
in the moment of crisis.
But as I said,
some people when I say tell them to relax,
they just look at me like I'm crazy
because they don't want to relax.
They're losing ground so they
want to work night and day.
And if they want to,
I can't really teach them who they are.
They know who they are
and so I think that I need to support them
for what they want to do.
- Yeah, that's really
important, really well said.
I love hearing about
that flexibility as well
because it ties back to the point
that you both made at
the beginning as well
that things really seem to be continuing
in terms of the work and the productivity
and that just shows me the flexibility,
even though some might
say that's detrimental
from the way that you build it,
it has not been detrimental at all
as things have continued
and as people have been able
to continue to move forward.
But to your point, Luigi, as well,
just the individuality that's there
and people have to know themselves
and what works for them.
But Amy, it still sounds like in some ways
you're also empowering people
by just saying that you
are going on vacation
and people are having the freedom
to incorporate that as well.
So it seems like on all layers,
you're showing that
but then also people are still
learning from it as well.
But I think it's such an important point
to know that it's an
individually based piece.
With new trainees that come in,
I always tell them how I've had trainees
that I've had to tell to
spend more time in the lab
because they weren't
putting the effort in,
but I've also had trainees
I've had to tell to spend
less time in the lab
because they were spending
so much time overthinking,
basically running themselves into a wall,
spreading themselves thin
that when they took a pause,
they were like, oh, I can
actually think more clearly
and use my time more efficiently
and they actually got more
productive spending less time.
That's obviously dangerous to share
because sometimes people could be tempted
to take that to extremes,
but I think it's important to know
that that balancing act is
there and people need to know
where they need to take their breaks
and where they need to
continue to move forward.
- By the way, Amy, during the weekend
I made tomato sauce and peach jam so.
- I can't wait to come to your house
and eat some of it, Luigi.
- You can try them.
- Yes, there's definitely a
food vibe going on here as well.
You both are gonna have to be careful
because you're gonna
have a lot of requests
after this episode once people hear that.
- One of the things that
Luigi did before the pandemic,
and I'm sure he'll do it again,
because we're really limited
with what we can do with awards,
so like poster awards
and things like that,
you know, they get a little
paper plate, paper flap,
and Luigi has the winners
to his house for dinner.
I mean that's a really big sentiment.
I love that and I think
that I would love to
be able to do that too.
Yeah, it's pretty cool.
- That sounds like a
great incentive to me.
- Trust me, if you've ever had-
- Well come and visit and you know,
some Italian food,
you will not be hungry, I promise you.
- I'm excited already.
Well I know that our time
has gone very quickly here,
which doesn't surprise me
and perhaps we'll have to do this again
in the future as well,
but just to tie in
and I'm just curious to hear
from both of you what you're,
what you're hopeful for
in the months ahead.
I mean you've both talked
about some of the resilience
and the ways that we've been creative,
but what are you hoping
for as scientific directors
and for your institutes and your trainees
as we move forward?
Luigi, we'll start with you this time.
I know that's not a light question.
- Well, you know, as I said,
I hope that the grief of
COVID-19 will be a released soon
and then we can take back our journal,
but with the new awareness
of what this pandemic taught us
and how important it is to
remain connected as a community
and how, as you said before,
maintaining flexibility
will not put us down,
but it will actually
support us as a community
and make us more productive.
I think that my hope that
will come out from this
fast enough so that we can fully recover.
I have a little bit of fear too.
And the fear is that if this
thing goes on for long time
that process language,
that connection that we had,
as more new people come in
that will be lost and will
be very, very difficult
to recreate,
it will be a measured effort
to recreate that language
that is informal and that is not verbal.
And I can certainly, I will certainly try
to push that project,
but in the back of my mind,
that's what I'm afraid of,
although in general, I'm very positive
attitude on this.
- Right, I appreciate
that honesty.
- And I want
to embrace people.
I want that.
That's what I want.
I want the world of
friendship and connection.
- Yes, definitely hoping
and looking forward to that as well.
Amy, what about you?
- I think that for me
the thing that I'm most excited about
is that during this time period
as I've just become the SD
and under the under the
whole pandemic thing,
we've been working pretty
hard behind the scenes
to make some pretty big changes
in the way that we do business at NIDA.
And I am so excited to see this pan out.
And I feel like we've
got the next year or two,
there's a lot of new things
that we're bringing in.
and really I hope pushing the translation
that I've always wanted to
have happen as a chemist.
I'm really sure that
I've cured enough rats
of cocaine abuse,
that I'd really like to
get that beyond rats.
And I think that we've got,
we're putting some things in place
that I think are gonna be fantastic.
We've got some new recruits
that are not only fantastic themselves,
but very committed to diversity,
I think are gonna really bring in
some new ideas for outreach
and I'm just can't wait
for that to happen,
but I recognize that it's not
going to happen right away.
So I guess that what I'm hopeful for
is that the lessons that we've learned
and the resilience that we've demonstrated
in the last 18 months
will continue to follow us
as we deal with whatever this coronavirus
is going to deal to us.
And I'm an optimist,
we're going to get through this
and we're going to be better for it.
It's just, we just have to hang in there.
- Mmm, mmm, so well said.
Well I'm excited to hear about
the new initiatives as well
and all that's been brewing
and that you've all
been working on so hard.
And I also appreciate
I know just the sense
between you and Luigi
and just the comradery
amongst the institutes
and the similar aligning
and parallel goals in a lot of ways.
So it's encouraging for me to hear
just the way that things have
continued to move forward.
Definitely interested in
doing an extended conversation
at some point as well
and even coming back to some
of these ideas in the future.
So hopefully at some point in person,
even though we've all been
virtual up to this point,
but definitely appreciate it.
Go ahead, go ahead.
- Anytime.
- Excellent.
Well it's been great meeting
both of you officially.
I know we've corresponded
beforehand and I appreciate
again, just your level of candor
that you shared on this Addy Hour podcast.
I know this is gonna be a
unique setup in a lot of ways
but it's something that I
think will really be important
as we peel back the layers.
So thank you again to Dr. Amy
Newman, Dr. Luigi Ferrucci
for being willing to come
and to join on this Addy Hour podcast.
And to all our listeners,
have some exciting episodes
coming up in the future as well
so definitely stay tuned.
(upbeat music)